LAURENCE MORONEY: Welcome
to the Googleplex.
This is an incredible place
with lots of great stuff being
worked on every single day.
Before I worked here,
I always wondered
what it would be like to
come to the Googleplex,
meet up with a Googler,
and have coffee with them
and just chat about what
they do, how they do it,
and why they do it.
And today, We're going
to do exactly that.
Welcome to this episode of
"Coffee With a Googler."
And if you, like me,
love games and love
3D games and all
that kind of stuff,
then this show should
be a treat for you
because today I'm chatting
with Shannon Woods, who's
a technical program manager.
And she works on our
rendering teams at Google.
And she's got lots
of great stuff
to talk about in the 3D space.
So welcome, Shannon.
How are you?
SHANNON WOODS: I'm
doing all right.
How are you?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Really good.
I have to say, I'm really
envious of your job.
Could you us what you do?
SHANNON WOODS: So I work with a
couple of rendering teams here
at Google, both
Android and Chrome.
And we sort of plumb code from
user space down to your GPU.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
Can you translate that?
SHANNON WOODS:
Basically, our job
is to get a bunch of
triangles from applications
down to the GPU as
fast as possible.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
And all graphics are ultimately
made up of triangles, right?
SHANNON WOODS: Basically.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now
recently, you announced Vulcan.
And this is this new and
improved 3D rendering API.
Could you tell us
a bit about it?
SHANNON WOODS: Historically,
Android and all mobile phones
really have used OpenGL ES
to communicate to the GPU
within the phone to tell
it how to draw scenes.
But unfortunately,
over time, the API
has become less and
less of a good match
for what the hardware's
actually doing beneath.
So what would
happen is you would
use this API to communicate
a lot of the details
about your scene.
And the GPU has to
reorganize all of that
so that it can
consume it efficiently
and draw it on the screen.
So what Vulcan is--
it's another API
from the same open standards
group that makes OpenGL.
And it's designed to
be a lot closer to what
the hardware actually
does beneath the covers.
So if you provide
the data via Vulcan,
it should be able to
draw a lot quicker.
Sort of the flip side of
that is that it gives you
all of this control.
But it means that you have to
be pretty good at making sure
that your code is doing exactly
what you wanted it to do.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Vulcan and OpenGL ES
are both from the same
standards body, right?
SHANNON WOODS: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So that's "Khronas"?
SHANNON WOODS: Yes.
Khronos.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Khronos, sorry.
So you work with the
standards body at Khronos?
SHANNON WOODS: I do.
I get to travel all
around the world
and see beautiful
conference rooms.
But it's actually
really interesting
getting to see how the API
is made from the ground up.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
SHANNON WOODS: Android is
going to support both OpenGL ES
and Vulcan.
So developers can
choose which API
is right for what they're
doing, like if they
need to render a FPS game, a
first person shooting game that
has to run really fast at a
high frame rate, then they're
going to probably want to choose
Vulcan so that they can closely
control exactly what's
being drawn and when.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
SHANNON WOODS: But
if they just want
to get a couple of
shapes onscreen,
then OpenGL ES is probably
still the right choice for them.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool, cool.
So it's just really
nice to have both.
SHANNON WOODS: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
And from my understanding,
you were saying with Vulcan,
just being able to get
down to the chipset level
effectively allows you to
squeeze a lot more performance
out of the machine.
SHANNON WOODS: Yeah, it does.
And one of the other
things that it does
is that it allows for
greater parallelization.
There's a lot of work in OpenGL
ES that it's blocking work.
You make a call into OpenGL
ES, into the driver code,
and it has to stop
and perform the task
that you asked it to do
and doesn't return control
to the application until
it finishes that task.
And what this means is that
if you have multiple threads,
only one of them can really
be talking to the driver,
doing these things
at the same time.
Vulcan is designed more for
multi-threaded applications
so that you can have
multiple threads doing things
like constructing buffers full
of commands at the same time.
LAURENCE MORONEY: You're
getting onto, like,
programming and skills.
And from a skills
perspective, are there
things that developers
will need to learn
that they don't do
already, for example,
if they're doing 3D
games in OpenGL ES?
SHANNON WOODS: So
the skill sets are
going to be largely the same.
As a Vulcan developer,
you're going
to have to have probably
a tighter handle on things
like synchronization, careful
tracking of memory allocation
because a lot less of
that is going to be
done for you by the driver.
The upside of this
is that the driver
won't be doing these things
when you don't expect it to.
But you're going to
have to really hone
your skills at things like
multi-threaded synchronization,
memory allocation, make sure
that you are closely keeping
an eye on what
your code is doing
and what it's
asking the GPU to do
because the driver is going
to do a whole lot less of that
for you.
It's not going to
clean up after you.
It's not going to check that
you're making legal calls.
So you're basically going to
have to be a bit of a ninja.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It's
almost like driving stick
versus driving manual, right?
SHANNON WOODS: That's probably
a really good analogy.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So people
can learn about Vulcan
on the Khronos site?
SHANNON WOODS: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
that's khronos.org or--
SHANNON WOODS: Khronos.org.
www.khronos.org.
And Khronos is
spelled K-H-R-O-N-O-S.
And they have a
Vulcan landing page,
where you can find the latest
news about Vulcan and also see
some of the presentations
that were given, for example,
at SIGGRAPH this year and at
GDC about the shape of the API.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
Now you were at SIGGRAPH, right?
SHANNON WOODS: I was SIGGRAPH.
LAURENCE MORONEY: How did it go?
SHANNON WOODS: It was
a lot of fun actually.
We did some demos, showed
some spinning teapots.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Teapots?
SHANNON WOODS: So
there's a little bit
of history behind the teapot.
The teapot is canonically
called the Utah teapot.
And it's because way back in the
history of computer graphics,
it's one of the first models
that was digitized and shared.
And interestingly, so
the teapot everybody
knows, that they've seen here
and there over the years-- it
looks short and squat.
But the reason for
that is actually
that on the original
display system,
the pixels were not square.
So they had a different--
LAURENCE MORONEY: The
tiny little ones from TVs?
SHANNON WOODS: Yeah,
the aspect ratio
was a little bit different.
So in real life, the teapot's
actually a little taller.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Now you're saying
that the pixels are elongated?
They were rectangular
pixels because this
was done so long ago?
SHANNON WOODS: Oh, yeah.
It was-- oh, gosh.
I guess it was the '70s.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
So the first 3D model that
was formed in cyberspace
or whatever you want to
call it back in the '70s.
And you're still using
the same model today
to-- I think Pixar also
use the teapot, don't they?
SHANNON WOODS: Yeah.
Actually, the teapot
appears in every Pixar film.
And one of the ones I know
off the top of my head
is-- they use it in the tea
party scene in "Toy Story."
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
Naturally, that's where
a teapot would fit.
SHANNON WOODS: Yeah.
But there's one in
every Pixar film.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Thank
you so much, Shannon.
SHANNON WOODS: Thank you.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
thanks, everybody,
for watching this episode
of "Coffee With a Googler."
I don't know about you,
but I've learned a lot
about the kind of things that
can be done with 3D graphics.
And I'm really, really excited
about Vulcan coming to Android.
If you've got any
questions for me,
or if you've got any
questions for Shannon,
just please leave them
in the comments below.
We'll also link to the
websites in the description
of this video so that you
can follow those links.
And if you want to learn
anything else about great stuff
that Google has to
offer for Android
developers, Chrome developers,
and everybody else,
please subscribe to the
Google Developers channel.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]